tell us about what got you involved I
mean you were teacher before I think and
and then you become an activist what
made you do that yeah I saw the death of
Mike Brown in Ferguson Missouri and I
was called to action I used to teach
sixth grade math which was an incredible
job and they killed a kid Mike Brown was
a teenager and I was like I'll do
whatever I can to make sure this doesn't
happen what I know now is that a third
of all the people killed by strange in
the United States has actually killed by
a police officer which is sort of wild
so it's been a long fight it's five
years this August when the protests
began what did you do I mean when you
decided you needed to do something what
did you do you needed to do yes I was
one of the many people in the street and
I said one of the biggest platforms in
the United States I was the most
referenced person in the world during
the protest but I was one of many people
who stood in the street and sort of push
back we were industry for 400 days you
know it was illegal to stand still in
August September and October of 2014 if
we stood still for more than five
seconds we were arrested which is really
wild come a long way but got a lot of
work to do so it was what physical
resistance and on street protests of
mobilization and the protest didn't
spread all across the country because in
2014 people thought there was a problem
in Ferguson they didn't realize there
was a problem in America and like over
time people realize like wow like the
police actually killing a lot of people
so how do we actually get to a system of
accountability injustice and that's
we've been working towards has it
manager still fit not stop it you know
it do you think that people confuse a
change in conversation with the change
in outcomes the police killed more
people in 2018 and in 2017 which is not
good well we know today that we did know
in 2014 is that they're actually a set
of laws policies and practices that
protect the police from accountability
so California our biggest state has a
law that says any investigation of an
officer the last more than a year can
never result in discipline regardless of
the outcome things like that are really
wild yeah there was of course a counter
blue lives matter people were saying
with reference to the police and also
this got caught up in them and they're
sort of crosshairs of racial politics in
America I mean is is it black lives
matter obviously saying that is this
primarily a racist you think it's
certainly a race issue and that's what
the the outcomes actually show us that
black people are more likely to be
killed disproportionately as a
proportion of
their population in the United States
and when we'd say to people is that like
if there were fires all across your
community you wouldn't say like let's
hire 50 more firefighters you'd be like
what is causing the fire it's maybe we
need smoke detectors build the houses
differently same there with crime when
there's an increase in crime the goal
isn't like more police officers the goal
is like what is causing the crime and
it's so many communities it's crimes of
addiction and crimes of power but if you
actually want crime to go down it's like
tackling those things even if you love
the police the best the police can do is
get there after the bad thing has
already happened
I mean you write about about your mother
who who was an addict and in this book
and left you effectively why is it that
given that level of social deprivation
some people go one way and other people
become math teachers yeah I think what
you find right is that like the the
communities that are the healthiest
communities are the safest actually have
the most resources not the most police
and I think about my own stories I like
my parents didn't grew up in a place
where they had a lot of resources right
I'm thankful that there were a lot of
adults who like provided support and
love and care for me and then what that
didn't require my mother to be there my
father raised us and a lot of other
adults but I'm also proud and I was one
of many people in the street and you got
my note of optimism to end yeah yeah you
know when we say that the system is
broken some people say oh no was
designed to be like that and my takeaway
as it was designed and because people
made it up we can make something better
[Music]
you